zion williamson of the new orleans
pelicans and to do the honors here is
the head coach
of memphis taylor jenkins
good evening i'm honored and filled with
so much joy to help present the 2019-20
kia nba rookie of the year award
to john morant congratulations ja what
an unbelievable rookie season
your competitiveness unselfishness and
drive to be great has earned you this
award
the first of many individual and team
accomplishments
in your bright future so today enjoy
this celebration with your family
and your team congratulations job
and we go to memphis and we are joined
by the kia nba rookie of the year john
moran congratulations to you
i appreciate it i appreciate it hey when
i when i look at your career and where
you came from to reach this point
uh i think it's a great story for kids
playing hoop
wherever because look you weren't this
highly touted player out of high school
you made your name at murray state and
now have made your name as the as the
nba rookie of the year tell me about the
journey and how satisfying it is to be
here tonight
um man it's you know it's a blessing um
definitely an honor
um you know i put a lot of work in uh
day in and day out um you know this this
journey
um it's been rough but you know at the
end it's all you know paying off
i know i still have a lot more work to
do but like you said for
you know guys or kids who you know not
heavily recruited right now
then you know just give them a lot of
hope so
joe what's up man it's draymond i see
you wasting no time getting the big boy
crib out there
obviously fans and everybody watching
the game are going to have what they
think
will help take you to the next level
which is your jump shot but as a player
i know you could possibly feel something
different so what's something that
everyone else isn't thinking that you
think can help take you to that next
level
after having such a great rookie year
uh man just you know um stand in love
with the grind
i always feel like it's you know always
room for improvement so i'm looking to
you know improve in every category most
of all for me it's you know my focus on
you know getting stronger
uh putting on weight to you know be able
to absorb contact
um i feel like that's the main thing
right now john this is shaq
that's your question wouldn't you be
honest we know you play with a lot of
character a lot of poise but as a rookie
was there one guy going up against that
made you kind of nervous
uh nervous um
no i wouldn't say it was nervous um it
probably was braun
just you know growing up watching him
play and
now you know taking the same floor as
him um it probably was that you know
wow moment i think it was more you know
anxiety just ready to get out there and
play
more than anything what was the
hardest thing and what was the easiest
thing about your rookie year
i think the hardest thing for me you
know just having to learn that
uh you you know you never can get too
high never get too low
um for me i you know i had a couple bad
games
um you know made some turnovers late in
the game that cost us a game and
um it's really just not you know uh
living a dime just by one i can't let
that
uh one bad game uh carry on to the next
um i think the easiest thing for me is
um you know probably um just coming here
and you know just being
vocal for my teammates um i had you know
a lot of vets
who talked to me throughout the season
who kept me you know continued in the
gym
studying film i felt like they made my
job
way easier joe i don't know if anybody's
told you the voting breakdown would you
be interested in knowing the voting
breakdown
uh yes you got 99 out of 100 first
place votes zion zion got the
the only other one of those kendrick
nunn was second zion was third and your
teammate
uh brandon clark was fourth
yeah i feel like um brandon definitely
deserved um that first team
he's played big definitely you know
still for us
we're happy we got him me him just got
to continue to continue to grow together
and
try to become you know one of the top
duos in this league
how are you going to celebrate tonight
um i got the fam here um actually inside
um ain't no telling what happened when i
walked back in the door
i'm a big family guy so i'm celebrating
with my family and most of all
my daughter she's here so yeah i know t
and jamie going to be very proud of you
and if it's really good video post it so
we'll
we'll run it on inside the nba
yes sir